21,5 Milliarden ja
Bildungsetat 21,5 Milliarden
Bildung und Forschung okay wie viel
davon geht in Bildung das ist Forschung
haben wir mehr weil das ja auch mehr
Bundesebene ist und es sind aber sehr
sehr viele Bund ländervereinbarungen die
wir in dem ETA haben es ist dann merken
wir schon da gibt es schon das Problem
wir können es noch nicht mal genau sagen
auf jeden Fall ich will sie ausdrücklich
loben erfolgreich sie haben den Etat um
900 Millionen sogar nach oben verhandelt
ja sie kennen ja auch den Finanzminister
sehr gut deswegen war das wahrscheinlich
möglich so und das Ergebnis aber
vielleicht schauen wir uns einfach mal
die folgenden Bilder an ist in Teilen
zumindest ein Desaster Gymnasium in
Pankow genau genommen das Gymnasium am
Europa Sportpark so sieht es da aktuell
aus
und ist nicht die einzige Schule
wahrscheinlich in Deutschland in der so
aussieht kennt irgendjemand hier in der
Runde dieser Schulen sie kennen die sie
kennen das nicht also ich kenne diese
Schule nicht sie kennen auch diese
Bilder nicht also ich kenne Bilder von
vielen Schulen aber diese Schule
speziell kenne ich nicht nein
das heißt sowas spricht sich dann auch
nicht rum bei in den Ministerien wenn
sowas sie wissen über die baulichen
Zustände Schulen bundesweit es gibt gute
Beispiele und schlechte Beispiele
katastrophal wenn man das hier sieht
ja ist ist das die Ausnahme oder ist das
etwas von dem man sagen muss leider viel
zu oft die Regel
in der
in dem Ausmaß ist es vielleicht nicht
überall so aber die Infrastruktur im
Bildungssystem ist nicht auf dem Stand
auf dem auf dem sie sein sollte ich
meine das sind mit die einzigen
Institutionen in unserer Gesellschaft
die keinen Sicherheitskonzept machen
konnten während der Pandemie wo die wo
man gemerkt hat die Fenster gehen nicht
auf warmes Wasser geht nicht Toiletten
sind nicht in dem vernünftigen Zustand
das heißt wir haben auch im
Bildungssystem auch in den im Hinblick
auf die Immobilien und die Grundstücke
riesen Problem das ist ganz sicher so
nach lautstarken Protesten hat Frau
Gefahr jetzt eine Renovierung für 40
Millionen also so hoch ist dieser
Renovierung Stau in Aussicht gestellt
und gibt noch eine zweite Schule wir
hören einfach mal ganz kurz rein wie die
Betroffenen das selbst erleben und für
mich ehrlich gesagt der Schultern zu
merken wir auch Schulleiter wie
verantwortliche wie unglaublich
resigniert die sind und wenn man das
hört fragt man sich woher soll da die
Inspiration für gut gelaunte Kinder
kommen wir hören mal kurz rein
Thule ist kurz vorm Zusammenbruch kurz
davor geschlossen
zu werden
Politiker in dieser Stadt
dass wir nicht in eine Lage kommen das
hier wirklich was passiert dann ist es
leider so dass es muss erst was
passieren bis dann jemand reagiert mein
Sohn kam eines Abends zu mir und hat
mich gefragt ob das denn jemals an einem
Tag gleichzeitig warmes Essen eine
saubere Toilette und Sportunterricht und
schönen Unterricht geben wird ich hoffe
dass man in der Gesellschaft erkennt
dass das ein ganz großes und ganz
wichtiges Problem ist was man nicht so
nebenbei behandeln kann
wie kann das sein
das ist jahrelang jahrzehntelang nicht
genug in Schulen investiert worden das
ist
aha es ist falsch da sind wir uns ja
alle einig wir müssen jetzt mit den
Problemen umgehen Schulbau ist jetzt
nicht bei mir das sind die Schulträger
vor Ort aber ich glaube wir müssen alle
zusammen jeder an seiner Stelle auch die
die Verantwortung übernehmen jetzt wenn
zum Beispiel sie jetzt sagen würden ich
sehe das Problem ich bin die
Bundesbildungsministerin sicher nicht
irgendwer ich habe auch diesen diesen
diesen diesen diesen durchaus
beeindruckenden Etat ich würde jetzt
gerne diese Schule renovieren sie
könnten das gar nicht nein das darf ich
grundgesetzlich nicht
und ist das gut wollen wir das weiter so
machen es wäre gut wenn wir uns alle
Bereiche die im Bildungswesen mehr
Investitionen brauchen die
Modernisierung brauchen die spezielle
Weiterentwicklung brauchen wenn wir uns
zusammen anschauen und dann die
Aufgabenteilung auch haben und dann
zusammen für die Finanzierung zusammen
streiten auf jeden Fall
wo liegt das Problem
es ist eine Aufteilung zwischen Bund
Ländern und Kommunen für die das ist
jetzt Berlin das ist sozusagen
Stadt und Land sozusagen in Union aber
grundsätzlich ist das Land für
Lehrkräfte für und für für den Lehrplan
zuständig die Kommunen sind die Träger
der Schule in der Regel für das Gebäude
also auch für so fragen wie
Digitalisierung und so Fehler führend
zuständig auch Hausmeister und und all
das und der Bund versucht dann über bei
Pässe wenn ich das jetzt mal einzuwirken
also beispielsweise der der Anspruch auf
dem Kita Platz oder jetzt der kommende
Anspruch auf dem ganztags in der
Grundschule das sind bundesgesetzter
bundesinitiativen und das alles führt
dazu dass die Menschen auch die in einer
Schule arbeiten sehr unterschiedlich
angestellt sind
unterschiedlich bezahlt werden weil die
eben aus verschiedenen Töpfen mit
verschiedenen Kompetenzbereichen und und
im übrigen das ist wirklich dann eine
große Herausforderung daran was zu
ändern wir brauchen eigentlich sowas
ähnliches wie bei Corona auch dass die
Bundesländer zusammen mit dem Bund sich
zu sich austauschen wie man bestimmte
Dinge hinbekommt und am besten auch
schon die kommunalen Spitzenverbände mit
dabei hat weil es eben so breit okay so
breit ist die Problematik es geht nicht
nur um Lehrermangel es geht um die
Gebäude es geht um also es geht um die
die da drin sitzen über die reden wir
jetzt gleich vor allen Dingen aber ich
meine
wie oft sitzen wir jetzt eigentlich
schon hier und besprechen genau dieses
Thema und stellen immer wieder fest da
gibt es diese Strukturen da gibt es
offensichtlich die Gesprächskanäle gar
nicht um um wirklich darüber zu reden
was ist eigentlich braucht da gibt es
dieses gerade zwischen Ländern und
bunter sitzt die Arbeit
Bundesbildungsministerin und sagt na ich
würde ja
aber ich darf das gar nicht also im
übertragenen Sinn setzen wir seit
Jahrzehnten da und haben immer wieder
das gleiche Problem wir hatten ja vor
glaube ich 17 Jahren grob geschätzt auch
den Versuch einer Föderalismusreform das
ist schon Kern des Problems dass der
Föderalismus auf eine Weise in hemschuh
ist das haben während der Pandemie viele
Leute mitbekommen auch am eigenen Leib
dann gespürt dass am Ende irgendwie 16
Bundesländer miteinander irgendwie so in
Einklang zu bringen in bestimmten
Bereichen so herausfordernd sein können
dass ich ja aus meiner Perspektive
nämlich der digitalisierungsperspektive
sagen würde es ist unverantwortlich die
Digitalisierung in der Bildung in
Ländern zu lassen das ist bisher eine
große Katastrophe nicht in allen
Bundesländern aber im Schnitt dann doch
wieder ähm das ist relativ klar dass
wenn die Digitalisierung der Bildung in
diesem Land gelingen soll dann muss der
Bund das an sich ziehen und ich weiß
dass da müssen jetzt Grundgesetzänderung
her was mir erstmal völlig egal was das
ich möchte das am Ende wir können das
dann von der anderen Seite sehen wenn
dieses Land in 20 Jahren noch wohlhabend
sein soll wenn überhaupt was da sein
soll um es zu verteilen was Umverteilung
angeht dann müssen wir die
Digitalisierung und speziell die
digitale Transformation schaffen also
den Wandel durch die Digitalisierung und
das ist eine Bildungsfrage und wenn wir
das nicht schaffen die Bildung digital
zu machen um zu lernen wie
Digitalisierung funktioniert dann sind
wir in 20 Jahren kein wohlhabendes Land
mehr das heißt aus meiner Sicht muss der
Bund jetzt sagen liebe Länder sorry
Digitalisierung in der Bildung ihr habt
es lange probiert ihr habt das sagen wir
mal im Durchschnitt einzelne super
Bayern ganz toll vielen Dank im
Durchschnitt habt ihr es verbockt das
müssen wir jetzt machen sonst gibt's auf
die Nase hätte ich bei einer gesagt aber
ich bin gegen Gewalt so
vorsichtiger aus Sicht der Wirtschaft
kann das doch auch nicht gewollt sein an
Land wie dieses das keine Rohstoffe hat
wir können keine Erdgas verkaufen auch
kein Erdöl und so weiter aber wir haben
eine einen Rohstoff von dem wir immer
geliebt haben deutsche Ingenieurskunst
ja gut ausgebildete Menschen wenn sie
sowas hören dass das Bildungssystem was
jetzt Grundschule angeht sind wir jetzt
auf das Niveau von PISA 2000 runter ein
Fünftel aller Kinder erreichen nicht
einmal mehr die Mindeststandards in
lesen und matte unter Trend geht weiter
nach unten gute Finanzpolitik wäre das
anzugehen weil ehrlicherweise sind die
Schulden die wir dieses Jahr aufnehmen
im Vergleich zu diesen Schulden die wir
aufhäufen nicht gut ausgebildete
[Musik]
Arbeitskräfte für die Zukunft das sind
die viel viel größeren Schulden da geht
es jedes Jahr um Steuereinnahmen also
ich sage das mal ganz kaltherzig nur
aufs ökonomische reduziert da geht es um
Steuereinnahmen von Unternehmen
Einkommensteuer da geht es um
Sozialleistungen die wir nicht zahlen
müssen weil die Menschen genug verdienen
und das kann ich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen also wie wir auf der
einen Seite wirklich so viel Zeit damit
verbringen jedes Jahr unsere
Neuverschuldung auf ein bestimmtes Maß
hinzubegrenzen und dann uns darum nicht
kümmern das sind die großen
Investitionen die wir unbedingt tätigen
müssen wir haben gar nicht gespart wir
haben einfach Investitionen ausgelassen
das ist nicht spannend das ist also echt
spannend für dumme
kann man nicht anders sagen es ist nicht
echtes Spahn wenn man notwendige
Investitionen eben nicht nicht tätigt
und
sie haben es jetzt gerade gesagt die
Menschen waren unsere Ressource wir
haben jetzt zwei Probleme quantitativ
werden immer weniger
und die Qualität haben sie gerade schon
angesprochen die Qualität der Ausbildung
der Kompetenzentwicklung verschlechtert
sich das beides zusammen ist wirklich
ein verheerendes Problem und die
Tatsache
so ging ja auch in die Richtung ging ja
auch Ihre Frage dass alle so ruhig
bleiben
warum geht kein Aufschrei durchs Land
wenn du mit kriegst dass du dass du fünf
klässler hast Viertklässler hast die
können nicht ordentlich lesen ich möchte
da das Problem ist nicht verstanden es
gibt kein Problem Bewusstsein in der
gesamten Gesellschaft ist das Problem
Bewusstsein nicht richtig ausgeprägt ich
habe aber noch ein anderes recherchiert
die vielleicht damit zu tun haben könnte
wir haben in Deutschland so zwischen 13
und 14 Millionen Eltern von
minderjährigen Kindern und wir haben 21
Millionen Mitglieder im ADAC ja einfach
mal so direkt gegenübergestellt und sehr
gespannt vielleicht könnte das damit zu
tun haben dass am Ende die Lobby von
denjenigen die für die Kinder
verantwortlich sind doch nicht so groß
ist wie man denkt weil zum einen
und zum zweiten ist es in diesem Land
wahnsinnig anstrengend Kinder zu haben
und es ist teuer Kinder zu haben und
dann wenn man so intensiv arbeitet um
Kinder groß zu ziehen dann auch noch auf
der Straße dafür zu kämpfen dass die
eine vernünftige Schule haben da habe
ich eine Hochachtung vor den Eltern die
da vor der Tür standen aber die
allermeisten Eltern gerade von mehrere
Kinder da muss man vor der Tür stehen
man kann ja nicht mehr rein es war ja
abgesperrt ne die Schule die wir gerade
gesehen haben
aus meiner Sicht fehlt den Eltern die
Kraft die notwendigen Kämpfe überhaupt
durchführen zu können und es ist eine
Schande dass diese Kämpfe notwendig sind
eigentlich müsste der Staat hier
vorsorgen absolut aber das fehlende
Problembewusstsein erkennt man daran
dass er eigentlich diejenigen die die
größte Wählergruppe sind nämlich die
geburtenstarken Jahrgänge die jetzt den
nächsten 15 Jahre in Rente gehen die
wird es am stärksten treffen deren Rente
deren Gesundheitsleistung und so stehen
auf dem Spiel wenn die jetzigen
Grundschüler die Sie gerade zitiert
haben die Studie
das Problem wird den 15 Jahren ein
Problem
sind die alle 20 Jahre alt dann werden
die in in der Schule in den Arbeitsmarkt
kommen und und jetzt tun wir ja dann
aber nicht so dass das jetzt was ganz
Neues ist seit zehn Jahren geht es
runter das heißt jetzt genau jetzt wo
der Fachkräftemangel anfängt wir sind
sozusagen die erste Stufe dieses Berges
genau jetzt haben wir die Problematik
dass das was das Bildungssystem
produziert nicht nur dass wir
quantitativ weniger haben da kann das
Bildungssystem nichts für sondern dass
wir qualitativ das entscheidende Punkt
aus ihrer Sicht und dann bin ich sehr
gespannt auf die anderen in der Runde an
welcher Stelle haben wir nicht
aufgepasst warum warum passiert sowas
also warum verlieren wir dermaßen unsere
Kinder aus den Augen und schaffen es
nicht mal mehr den ordentlich Lesen und
Schreiben zu vermitteln ich meine diese
von der Uni Wald weit weg aber auch für
Ausbildung im Handwerk zum Teil in meine
wenn man sich heute in Elektriker
anguckt was der können muss der muss
rechnen können da muss eine Idee von
Physik haben der muss eine Ahnung davon
haben wie die Dinge zusammenhängen
funktioniert auch nicht also Bildung hat
ja für mich drei wesentliche Merkmale
das eine ist erstmal selbstbestimmt weil
wir sind ja alle nicht geboren mit
Selbstbestimmtheit ich muss mir an
meinem Leben zurechtfinden und das
kriegt man auch nur durch Bildung dann
dass ich mein Einkommen erzielen kann
und dann eben auch für die gesamte
Wirtschaft und natürlich fragt man sich
warum passiert das und ich würde es ein
bisschen erweitern von dem was Sascha
Logo gesagt hat weil ich glaube die die
sich leisten können die Zeit investieren
können die gucken nach den Kindern die
gucken dass sie ihre Bildung bekommen
aber wir verlieren ja gerade diejenigen
die die Unterstützung aus
verschiedensten Gründen nicht haben
können und deswegen sehen wir ja auch
die Zahlen dass eben die Herkunft immer
noch so stark über den weiteren
Bildungsweg entscheide und deswegen
müssen wir schauen dass wir hier den
Durchbruch schaffen jenseits von
baulicher Substanz
die Frage von Respekt wie man wie man
auch mit jungen Menschen umgeht und auch
mit wir wollen ja tolle attraktive
Talente in in den Lehrberuf ziehen den
müssen wir auch tolle Räume in denen sie
dann möglichst selbstständig auch
agieren können geben so und das müssen
wir denn jetzt machen wir müssen
besonders im ersten Schritt da ansetzen
wo die Unterstützung nicht ist und
deswegen freue ich mich dass also auch
mit den Ländern zusammen dass wir uns
auf den Weg machen mal
Startchancen Programm aufzulegen das ist
noch nicht flächendeckend alles aber es
soll eben Struktur verändern sein eine
gute bauliche
Substanzen super bauliche Substanz damit
auch alles stattfinden kann das ist die
Grundvoraussetzung aber dann auch
zusätzlich zum zum regulären Budget ein
Chancen Budget das eben die Lehrerin und
Lehrer Verordnung mal speziell fördern
können oder aber auch Theater also je
nachdem was an in dieser
Schulgemeinschaft sinnvoll ist
anzubieten um auch die soziale Teilhabe
zu ermöglichen und dann eine dritte
Säule die mehr in Schulsozialarbeit oder
aber auch wie man so schön sagt
multiprofessionelle Teams warum wir
müssen etwas verändern und wir wollen
das wissenschaftlich begleiten lassen
weil ich glaube wir müssen lernen wo wir
erfolgreich sind ist besser zu machen
und wir müssen uns auch immer wieder
selber prüfen haben wir das erreicht was
wir erreichen wollen damit wir die
nächsten Schritte oder damit wir auch
anpassen müssen und wir wollen starten
mit den Ländern um gerade denen die eben
nicht die Unterstützung bekommen von zu
Hause noch mal die Chance zu geben eben
die drei Aspekte von Bildern die Frage
wenn das so wichtig ist und wenn das so
großartig ist warum starten sie denn mit
der 2024 25 weil das natürlich also das
hat ja auch ein gewissen Vorlauf wir
wollen das wissenschaftlich aussetzen
2020 es ist nicht so dass wir nicht
ungeduldig sind und dass wir das schnell
machen müssen aber es sind die Fragen
wie ist aufgesetzt wird es müssen die
bauliche Voraussetzungen geschaffen
werden wir haben jetzt in wir sind echt
den konstruktiven Gesprächen dass wir
dann 2024 starten können weil wir wollen
jetzt es wirklich gut machen es soll
Struktur verändern sein es soll
selbstständige wir haben jetzt über
zentrale Verantwortung gesprochen ich
bin der Meinung es muss unheimlich viel
Verantwortung auch in die Schulen direkt
damit das einfach die Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer nicht nur Erfüllungsgehilfen von
unserer Schulbürokratie sind dass sie
wirklich Lernbegleiter sein können das
heißt wir wollen damit wirklich was
bewirken ja es wäre schöner wir könnten
es gestern machen aber wichtig ist das
ist jetzt kommt und das ist auch gut
wird und das ist ein Anstoß ist auch
noch mehr zu verändern
4.000 Standorte sollen das sein ne die
davon profitieren von diesem Programm
4000 schwierige Schulen gute Chancen für
jedes Kind für die Kinder die dort
hingehen und die Länder sind natürlich
auch die haben schon einige Programme
können das Erweitern es gibt Stiftungen
die dort aktiv sind müssen alle Kräfte
bündeln ja das ist der das ist der
Anfang eine Frage diese 4000 Schulen
wissen Sie eigentlich welche 4000
Schulen das sind die Schulen bewerben
sich es gibt auch bestimmte Kriterien
die angelegt werden sie aus ihrem
Ministerium heraus sagen okay da haben
wir Daten die uns eindeutig darauf
hinweisen genau an dem Punkt ist es
nötig genau da sollten wir reingehen na
gut es gibt ja sogenannte sozialindizes
da sind die Länder jetzt im Gespräch ob
sie ein einheitlichen haben man kann
schon annähernd ich würde nicht sagen
dass wir in Deutschland punktgenau Daten
haben müssen wir in dem Fall aber
vielleicht auch nicht man kann sich dem
annähern da würde ich heftig oder so
reingehen in dieses Programm genau also
zum einen wo der Startchancen einfach
ein Jahr nach hinten verschoben das
heißt man war im letzten Jahr am Anfang
noch ein bisschen optimistischer das ist
nach hinten verschieben okay keine Krieg
da kann man jetzt sogar diskutieren aber
der Punkt ist halt schon das höre ich
jetzt sehr sehr oft wir brauchen ja gar
nicht so gute Daten aber die Realität
ist das die Datenlage katastrophal ist
es gibt keinen funktionierenden
Rückkanal und zwar im
digitalisierungskontext besonders nicht
wo es einfach wäre und das heißt konkret
wir haben eine Vielzahl von
Bildungsmaßnahmen in der Digitalisierung
und diejenigen die aufsetzen finanzieren
vorantreiben die Wissen in dem
seltensten Fällen wie das wirkt und das
ist für jede digitale Vorgehensweise mit
komplette Katastrophe und das ist auch
ein Punkt da könnten sie die Länder
unter Druck setzen weil ich weiß dafür
föderal und Bildung und dann kann man
als Bildungsministerin manchmal nur bit
betteln ja und dann kann man irgendwie
über der KMK das ist
Kultusministerkonferenz ist und
politisches Gremium was etwa mit der
Geschwindigkeit der kontinental trifft
voranschreitet aber der Punkt ist sie
können sehr sehr schnell sehr sehr
schnell und Sie können Sachen bewirken
zum Beispiel beim Einfordern von Daten
und dass das bis jetzt nicht passiert
ist halte ich für ein großes Versäumnis
denn wir wissen ganz viele Sachen
schlicht nicht wir wissen nicht wie hat
x gewirkt wie hat y gewirkt wie hat es
gewirkt dazwischen durch irgendwie ein
paar Millionen Kindern iPads bekommen
haben nur was ein bisschen schwieriger
war dann die entsprechenden
Systemadministratoren dazu zu bekommen
und da präzisere Daten zu haben aktuelle
Daten zur Steuerung das wäre aus meiner
Sicht eine fantastische Aufgabe für Sie
ist aber auch kein Widerspruch zwischen
uns beiden das ist auch etwas wenn wir
neue Bund-Länder Programme auflegen dann
ist das immer ein integraler Bestandteil
denn wir sehen ja auch in dem
iqb-bericht also in dem Bericht den sie
erwähnt haben Kompetenzen der
Grundschülerinnen und Grundschüler die
Länder die Anfang mit Daten zu arbeiten
und nicht um die Kinder zu sagen du bist
schlecht oder diese Schule schlecht aber
einfach zu sehen wo müssen wir noch
zusätzlich was machen die Länder können
sich ja kontinuierlich auch ein Stück
weit verbessern und deswegen ist es
Grundvoraussetzung dass wir wissen wo
wir stehen wir brauchen
Lernstandserhebungen wir brauchen die
Daten ob wir unsere Ziele erreichen das
muss unser Ansehen sein und das soll
auch integraler Bestandteil sein wird
auch Teil des Bildungsgipfel sein das
ist auch das was die Länder sich in der
Kamera jetzt ne ja wir reden jetzt ganz
viel darüber wie wir diese Programme
richtig gute seinen und dass wir die
richtigen Daten brauchen das ist ja
alles richtig
aber ich frag mich nicht ob manchmal die
Lösungen auch ein bisschen einfacher
sind oder bisschen früher anfangen
nämlich wir brauchen mehr Geld wir haben
jetzt über schulische Bildung geredet
frühkindliche Bildung ist ökonomisch
bewiesen dass den größten return
überhaupt hat auch sehr sehr gut ist um
dafür zu sorgen dass alle die gleichen
Startchancen haben und da ist auch so
ein eklatanter Mangel wo man sicher mit
Geld ziemlich viel bewirken könnte jetzt
habe ich mir aber gerade das
nachfolge-gesetz vom gute Kita-Gesetz
angeguckt und da sind zwei Milliarden
drin und die sind fix über Zeit also wir
geben 200 Milliarden jetzt mal schnell
so zur Krisen Bewältigung aus aber fix
jedes Jahr in einer Zeit in der alles
teurer wird und Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher sicher nicht überbezahlt sind
Kindergartenleitung verdient weniger als
ein Referent der im
Bundesfinanzministerium anfängt und wir
sagen wir halten das Fix
und ich glaube da gibt es ein paar
Sachen die sind schon einfacher als so
Programme richtig gut zu designen und
das braucht eigentlich nicht so viel
Zeit da könnte man direkt was machen ja
das ist alles total gut wir sind nur zu
spät also wir um jetzt erstmal in dem
Bild zu formulieren das ist so als
würden wir den Bremsweg noch ausrechnen
wo eigentlich schon klar ist dass der zu
lang ist wir fahren vor die Wand und wir
rechnen noch aus ob wir das ist also die
falsche Reihenfolge die die Finanzierung
ist ist das eine und da muss was gemacht
werden die die Länder die Kommunen alles
alle die am im Bildungssystem beteiligt
sind könnten besser arbeiten wenn Sie
die Gewissheit hätten das jetzt über
einen längeren Zeitraum mehr Geld
reinkommt man kann eh ohne hin nicht
sehr viel Geld auf einmal ausgeben das
in ein System was marode ist schafft es
ja nicht einmal Geld auszugeben gerade
wenn man sich wenn man Anträge schreiben
typischer Fall in in Deutschland dass
man alles beantragen muss alle
zusatzprojekte die da wo es brennt da
werden keine Anträge kommen also je
schlimmer es ist desto
unwahrscheinlicher ist es dass man sich
dass man dass man Geld da beantragen
kann wir brauchen eine völliges Umdenken
und ich komme da jetzt noch mal kurz
darauf zurück warum warum wir immer noch
so langsam sind das liegt daran dass das
Problem noch nicht verstanden ist also
ähm um das jetzt mal noch ein bisschen
weiter zu machen es wird gerade
diskutiert ob wir nicht nur unabhängiger
von Russland werden wollen sondern auch
unabhängiger von China diese Diskussion
bei dem Fachkräftemangel und bei dem
Problem im Bildungssystem braucht man
nicht zu führen wird was sollen wir denn
wieder an uns zu uns zurückholen wir
haben die Menschen dafür nicht und also
weder quantitativ und noch qualitativ
die wir diskutieren darüber und das ist
übrigens eine wichtige Botschaft wir
diskutieren darüber dass wir alle
Infrastruktur transformieren wollen
nicht nur digital sondern auch noch
klimaneutral würden wir die bestehende
Infrastruktur nur aufrechterhalten
müssen kriegt man es irgendwie hin mit
mit sinken von Fachkräften irgendwie
klar zu kommen aber dann auch noch alles
zu transform wer soll das Bauen wer soll
das entwickeln wie soll das umgesetzt
werden das ist alles eine Illusion und
da rede ich noch gar nicht darüber wie
die Renten finanziert werden sollen und
und und und es ist ungefähr so wie wenn
hier früher Leute gesessen haben und
gesagt haben er wert ist schon über eins
und alle meinen ich sehe noch nichts so
in etwa ist die Situation gerade nur
dass die Welle die jetzt hier gekommen
ist gerade die demografische die hat
sich Jahrzehnte 60 70 Jahre aufgebaut ja
ähm und die wird nicht wie eine Welle in
einer epidologie nach zwei drei vier
Monaten weg sein sondern das dauert
jetzt auch Jahrzehnte wir haben wirklich
ein richtig richtig krasses Problem ich
würde sagen das worüber wir reden ist
das größte innenpolitische Problem
mindestens für anderthalb Jahrzehnte und
wir versuchen zu unseren Kindern vor
starkem bevor wir gleich mal darüber
reden warum die
Grundschüler in bildungstechnisch auf
dem Niveau sind auf dem sie sind dieses
Programm dass sie gerade zitiert haben
auf dass sie erkennbar stolz sind wie
viel Geld diese diese 4.000 Schulen wie
viel Geld werden die am Ende kriegen
jeder einzelne Schule wissen sie das das
kommt da natürlich drauf es wird
wahrscheinlich auch unterschiedlich sein
je nachdem Voraussetzungen sind
dass das hängt davon ab wie viel die die
die
wie der chancenbudget bzw wie die
baulichen Voraussetzungen und sind und
wie viel Schulsozialarbeit wie groß die
Schule ist aber es ist geplant mit ein
bis zwei Milliarden von Bundesebene zu
starten um dann den Hochlauf zu schaffen
und dann muss man schauen wie man das
sukzessive aufbaut und was von den ähm
was von den Ländern noch ein bis zwei
Milliarden für 4000 Probleme nicht die
Länder geben ja auch einen Teil dazu und
insofern ist es ja es ist ja auch ein
Add-on an bestehende Schulen ist wenn er
nicht ganz neue Schule schon gesagt wie
viel Geld sie geben wollen da sind wir
ja gerade in den Verhandlungen ich weiß
sie wollen das jetzt gerne wissen und
ich weiß nein ich weiß noch diese
Gespräche sind und wie wenig
funktioniert diese diese Struktur ist
darauf will ich hinaus da bin ich da bin
ich ja bei Ihnen Herr Lanz aber schauen
Sie ich will sie gar nicht nein ist ja
in Ordnung ich will ja sagen wir müssen
ja auf den Weg machen und wir müssen uns
wieder zusammen den Gesamtgesellschaft
aber den Weg machen und ich höre das was
sie sagen und das sind natürlich alles
weil jede Punkte aber wir müssen ja mit
den Problemen umgehen und das eine ist
Geld das andere ist aber auch dass das
gut machen das hat was mit
frühkindlicher Bildung zu tun da bin ich
auf jeden Fall ja bei ihnen ich war
Kommunalpolitikerin da war die
Kinderbetreuung vor Ort eigentlich eher
eine lästige Aufgabe statt zu sagen wir
sind bildungskommunik hier fängt an hier
ist die Grundlage von dem ganzen
Lebensweg von von jungen Menschen da
müssen umdenken hinkommen das muss auch
Teil eben das Verständnis von Kommunen
sein nicht nur betreuen damit die Frau
oder der Mann arbeiten gehen kann ja uns
fehlen die Leute im Fachkräfte wir
müssen auch die Lehrer die fehlen uns
auch die Fachkräfte die Fachkräfte die
Fachkräfte deswegen machen wir einfach
Kräfte Einwanderung setzen nein das wird
nicht über Nacht alle Probleme lösen
aber wir müssen uns auf den Weg machen
und jetzt auch mal mit einem liberalen
Fachkräfte Einwanderung wo wir sagen es
können auch Leute mit beruflicher
Bildung zu uns kommen wir müssen
schneller werden in der Anerkennung all
das sind Themen da müssen wir uns auf
den Weg machen wird das über Nacht alles
funktionieren nein aber der Weg muss
klar sein und Lehrerin und Lehrer
absolut jenseits der Digitalisierung
was würden Sie sagen also in manchen
Bundesländern 4000 das können 5000
können Sie dann hochrechnen da gibt's
unterschiedliche Studien von der K&K es
gibt aber auch Studien von Professoren
Professoren die Aufgabe die ist ist eine
Mammut Aufgabe die vor uns liegt und ähm
das hat etwas auch damit zu tun dass der
Beruf attraktiv sein muss auch hier es
hat nicht nur mit Geld zu tun sondern
wir müssen uns überlegen wir müssen die
Lernorte der Zukunft aussehen wie müssen
die Kompetenzen ver ausprobieren was ist
interessant für Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
wie will ich arbeiten und das sind alles
Themen die müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam
angehen und nicht davor erschrecken die
Zahlen in Berlin sind gerade mal 60
Prozent der Lehrerstellen überhaupt
besetzt ja in Rheinland-Pfalz gab es
neulich eine Petition
von von Eltern die die Regierung zwingen
will 7000 neue Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
einzustellen uns fehlen mutmaßlich gibt
es unterschiedliche Zahl zwischen 40 50
oder 60.000 Lehrer in Hamburg zum
Beispiel ist es so wenn man
den Lehrermangel einfach ausgleichen
wollen würde dann müsste jeder zehnte
der gerade in der Uni ist auf Lehramt
studieren ist völlig illusistisch das
wird dich passieren woher kommen all
diese Menschen ja das ist ein Punkt wo
ich ja dann manchmal auch wenn wir viel
über Geld sprechen
auch mal den Punkt es nützt nichts nur
auch in meinem Bundesland Hessen sind
jetzt 4000 mehr Stellen in den Haushalt
geworden aber die Menschen sind gar
nicht da so auch hier wahrscheinlich
nicht die einfache Lösung wir müssen
natürlich viel besser sagen den in den
Zugang zum Studium warum brechen so
viele den
Lehramtsstudiengang ab da müssen die
Länder mit den Studierenden Lösungen
empfinden weil und man kommt auch sehr
spät in die Praxis dann muss angepasst
werden da muss nachgebessert werden auch
hier wird im im Anfang nächsten Jahres
von der ständigen wissenschaftlichen
Kommission noch mal gesammelt alle
Punkte die eben dazu führen warum wir
wieder Lehrberuf attraktiver werden kann
wir müssen über Quereinsteiger sprechen
es ist vollkommen illusorisch dass wir
über Nacht all das über ein Studiengang
schaffen wir müssen schauen dass wir
Praktiker in die Schule gekommen das ist
nicht ideal aber Sie müssen eben sie
müssen das Praktiker das zum Beispiel
ein Mathematiker dann in die Schule
wechselt Quereinsteiger so nennt man das
da gibt's ja heute schon warum machen
die
pädagogische Qualifizierung hat weil es
auch ein spannender Beruf ist weil man
vielleicht auch mal in der Mitte Lebens
sagt für mich ist das eine tolle
Berufung Lehrerin und Lehrer zu werden
man Studierende fragt warum sie das
Abbrechen dann passiert das auffällig
häufig nach dem Erstkontakt mit dem
System Schule und wenn man dann Lehrende
fragt in den Schulen dann sagen wir es
gibt einfach kein besseres Mittel um
innerhalb von einem halben Jahr alle
Visionen alle großen Zielen über Bord zu
werfen als den direkten Kontakt mit dem
deutschen Bildungssystem da werden Leute
in die Frustration reingeprügelt durch
eine völlige überbürokratie durch eine
fehlregelung durch teilweise absurde
Regulierungen wo sie im Detail überhaupt
kein Gestaltungsspielraum mehr haben
dazu kommt noch eine Ausstattung die man
irgendwie eher museal aufgestellt ist
als wirklich für die Zukunft geeignet
und ich wundere mich überhaupt nicht
warum wir zu wenig Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer haben sondern ich frage mich wie
die verbleibenden ist schaffen einfach
nicht katastrophal zu verzweifeln das
ist meine meine Frage stellen
ein bisschen zu diesem Punkt das ist
nicht nur das Geld wir machen oft diese
Gegenüberstellung und sagen es ist eben
entweder das Geld oder ist eine andere
Probleme das gehört doch zusammen und
der Anspruch sollte sein Geld gut
auszugeben also wir sagen wir haben so
diese lagerkämpfe Schulden oder keine
Schulden und es geht doch darum gute
Programme aufzusetzen die eben auch
bisschen langfristig sind und da werden
zum Beispiel die Taschenspieler Tricks
zum Problem weil man es eben nicht
langfristig machen kann also wir können
jetzt Geld in der Notlage aufnehmen in
die Tasche stecken und dann nächstes
Jahr ausgeben aber es ist eben nicht so
leicht strukturell mehr auszugeben für
Bildung und das auch geplant zu machen
weil wir können ja nicht sagen oh das
war eine Notlage Ausnahme und wir machen
jedes Jahr Notlage für Bildung und wenn
wir aber gut diese Programme planen
wollen und ich meine das finde ich
interessant von Ihnen zu hören wäre es
für sie nicht leichter wenn sie wüssten
sie hätten jetzt 15 Milliarden und mit
dem Problem Bildung umzugehen und zwar
auf die nächsten zehn Jahre jedes Jahr
dann tun sie sich doch sicher viel
leichter zu planen und systematisch
aufzubauen
wenn Sie schauen was wir für
Steuereinnahmen über Kommunen Bund und
Länder haben dann sollten wir das Geld
zusammenlegen und zusammen überlegen wie
man die Strukturen schafft ich will ja
nicht sagen dass Bildung nicht Geld
kostet dass man auch dafür kämpfen muss
dass mehr Geld im System ist aber ich
glaube wir müssen auch zusammen die
Mittel zusammenlegen und dann ein
Gesamtkonzept machen natürlich kann man
mit 15 Milliarden Euro viel anstoßen
aber es muss ja mit allen geteilt werden
und ich bin bin wirklich der Meinung wir
haben ja eben auch noch mal über
Lehrermangel gesprochen wir müssen es
kann sogar ein föderales System sein
aber wir müssen schauen dass wir
selbstständige Schulen haben damit der
Lehrberuf attraktiv wird ich meine sie
können es vielleicht aus eigener
Erfahrung noch sagen damit eben nicht
das passiert was sie eben geschildert
haben und damit die Gestaltungskraft für
Leute damit es interessant ist damit man
Motivation in den Schulen hält und die
Länder die dann mit Blick auf
Lehrerausbildung und Lehrpläne die
Aufgabe haben und der bunte in großen
Dingen die Digitalisierung die
Verantwortung hat
damit nicht zu viele Ebenen dabei sind
wo man gegenseitig auch Verantwortung
abgibt oder Bürokratie aufbaut das sind
ja die beiden Dinge und deswegen wenn
man zum Beispiel jetzt noch mal drüber
spricht wie machen wir ein digitalpakt
2.0 wir wissen dass der digitalpakt 1.0
gut war aber natürlich weder schnell
genug abgeschlossen ist noch auch der
Einsatz dann der äh
noch Daten erhoben wurden wie er ganz
konkret gewirkt hat sozusagen er ist gut
dass ein Anstoß gegeben wurde aber
natürlich muss ein muss ein digitalpakt
2.0 besser werden zur Hälfte sind sie
ich bin vollkommen Bein dass die Mittel
schneller abfließen müssen ich sag nur
wenn wir jetzt noch mal drüber sprechen
wie muss es aussehen dann müssen wir das
von Anfang an vom Ende her denken und
zwar so dass die das ist reibungsloser
läuft und die Bürokratie weniger ist es
gibt einen anderen Ländern Konzepte wo
schon erfolgreich umgesetzt worden ist
niemand Bildung modernisieren kann in
Dänemark gab es zum Beispiel einen
Ansatz dass man ein paar Schulen gesagt
hat so ihr könnt das machen was ihr
wollt für euch gelten die ganzen
Standard Regeln erstmal nicht ihr
begeisterte Leute die Lust haben was zu
verändern ihr könnt jetzt mal auf alle
normalen in Anführungszeichen Regeln die
Schulen sonst so unterliegen einfach
verzichten verzichten vielen Dank
und könnt erst mal vorankommen und das
waren sehr großer Erfolg und daraus
konnte man sehen es gibt ja Menschen die
was bewegen wollen und das konnte man
auch während der Pandemie sehen das kann
man in der Digitalisierung sehen es gibt
ganz viele tolle Sachen in Schulen wenn
die Schulleitung sagt wir haben da Lust
drauf wenn der entsprechende Lehrer und
Lehrerin sind die das machen und die
sich auch gut genug auskennen dann gibt
es fabelhafte Beispiele warum nicht die
die da schon ziemlich weit sind
unterstützen machen Sie doch mal einen
Kongress für die digitale Avantgarde der
Schulleiterinnen in Deutschland und
halten sie da eine ordentliche Rede ist
ich meine Idee sondern von Christian
Füller eine Idee ein Bildungsexperten
der machen Sie das doch mal setzen
Symbol für diejenigen die vorankommen
wollen das hat viel mehr Kraft als wenn
man irgendwie ewig mit der km/h
verhandelt ob jetzt das Konzept von 2016
was immer noch das aktuelle ist ergänzt
und ein paar komische Paragraphen und
man da nicht mal ein bisschen dran
schraubt